we begin though with a sharp escalation
in the rhetoric surrounding racial
unrest in this country
as pres as a presidential campaign
enters a brand new phase
there were new clashes in portland
overnight after a caravan of trump
supporters
waving flags arrived in the city over
the weekend now some of them
drove through a crowd pepper sprang
black lives matter
supporters later that night a man linked
to a right wing group was killed
we're also following the tensions in
kenosha wisconsin
where the latest demonstrations have
been largely peaceful
the president plans to visit the city
tomorrow
despite concerns from local officials
mololenki is in kenosha
with more on the nationwide unrest
these were the ten scenes in portland
saturday night
clashes broke out between pro-trump
demonstrators
and protesters calling for an end to
racial injustice
a pro-trump caravan of about 600
vehicles
had driven into the city saturday night
video shows trucks carrying people
waving pro-trump flags driving through
protesters
and pepper spraying people through open
windows
and these two gunshots led to the death
of one man
capping the violent night in the day
there was no no resolve and no mediation
and here we are and now there's
a dead body on the ground the tragedy of
last night
cannot be repeated portland mayor ted
wheeler denounced the violence in the
city and cast
blame on president trump for spreading a
message of hatred
you've tried to divide us more than any
other figure in modern history
and now you want me to stop the violence
that you helped create president trump
responded on twitter
writing wheeler thinks this lawless
situation should go on forever
wrong portland will never recover with a
fool for a mayor
protests have grown nationwide since the
jacob blake shooting in kenosha
this video shows officers in the
nation's capital breaking the windows of
a black lives matter van
pulling two people out and arresting
them and in tallahassee florida a man
drew a gun after scuffling with black
lives matter protesters
that man will not face charges
but here in kenosha the protests have
been largely peaceful over the last
several days about one thousand people
marched with jacob blake's family
saturday
calling for violence to end and for the
officers involved
to be disciplined there were seven
bullets
put in my son's back i'm standing here
with my sisters
and my brothers hell yeah i'm mad
as you can see by these paintings and
these murals behind me the city is now
trying to focus on a positive message of
healing
the wisconsin governor and attorney
general have both joined the mayor of
kenosha
in calling on the president to
reconsider his visit to kenosha here
mayor john aramian telling me yesterday
that the president is always welcome to
come but right now
may not be the best time the white house
tells cbs news that president trump is
looking forward to his visit on tuesday
to help the city heal and rebuild tony
all right muller thank you very much